Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I’m going to explain a science fiction
thriller film called “Freaks.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
Seven-year-old Chloe has never been out of
an abandoned house; she lives with her father,
Henry; her mother died years ago.
The movie starts as we see Chloe eyeing an
ice cream van outside her house through a hole.
There are some strange things outside Chloe's
house.
We see that the birds outside are not moving
and appear to be glitching.
The electricity in the house is always out,
and there seems to be no life outside the house.
Henry always gets furious when she peeks outside;
she is forbidden to leave the house in fear
of the bad men who killed her mother.
Henry is unsure of his safety.
So, he has prepared a plan in case something
bad happens to him.
He has made a deal with their neighbour, the
Reeds family.
In case of his absence, the Reeds will be
paid a steady amount of cash as long as they
take care of his daughter.
The family consists of a daughter named Harper,
a mother named Nancy, and a father named Steve.
One day, as the two play poker, Henry’s
eyes start to bleed.
That night while sleeping, Chloe heard a strange
noise from her closet.
She opens it to check, when suddenly, a woman
inside the closet screams.
Chloe too yells in fear.
She runs back to her bed, and starts to scribble
on the wall, repeating the words, “go away ghost"
Finally the screaming stops, and the ghost
is gone.
The following morning, Chloe wakes up to the
sound of an ice-cream truck, and peaks through
a window.
Her neighbor’s daughter, Harper, is buying
ice cream.
She whispers to Harper to bring it to her,
knowing that she won’t hear it.
However, soon after, someone knocks on the
doors.
Chloe rushes downstairs and opens the door.
Surprisingly, it is Harper, offering her the
ice cream.
Just as she is about to grab it, Henry from
behind her stops her.
Surprisingly again, Harper calls Chloe by
her name, Henry is confused, as he has never
introduced Chloe to anyone, so he quickly
brings her inside.
Henry is furious and asks her if she had met
Harper before, but Chloe insists that she
has never been out of the house, but he doesn’t
believe her and puts her into the closet as a punishment.
The following morning, Henry comes into the
closet and apologizes to her, but she is still
mad at him, and insists that she wants to
go out.
Henry promises to bring her ice cream if she
never opens the door again.
He then leaves for the grocery store, but
comes back injured with a gun in his hand.
As he mends his injuries, Chloe looks for
ice cream in the basket he has brought, and
finds no ice cream.
She starts to yell at her father, but he passes
out because of the injury.
Just then, Chloe hears the ice cream truck
ringing.
She gets a hundred-dollar bill from the locker
and goes outside.
The old man in the truck bribes her with an
ice cream cone, and persuades her to get inside
the truck.
She is doubtful, but gets in once he says
he will take her to the park.
They drive away, and Chloe sees the outside
world for the first time.
She sees a billboard of a person bleeding
from his eyes.
Below the picture, it says to call 9-1-1 if
you see someone like that.
Chloe mentions that the man bleeds like her
dad.
The old man then asks her if she has ever
bled like that, but Chloe denies it.
When they reach the park, the man sits Chloe
on a swing, and asks her if there is something
she can do that other people cannot.
But Chloe doesn’t answer, too busy playing.
Suddenly, he starts to swing her aggressively.
Chloe is scared and asks him to stop, but
the man tries to make her angry to surface
her powers.
Eventually, a policeman approaches them, and
asks him to step away from the girl.
The old man claims that he is Chloe’s grandfather,
but Chloe denies it.
The officer then asks Alan to show his eyes.
Alan turns to Chloe and tells him that the
officer is one of the bad guys who killed
her mother.
Chloe becomes upset and starts screaming at
the man to go away.
Surprisingly, it works; he goes away without
another word.
It turns out that Chloe has telepathic abilities,
the ability to enter and manipulate other
people's minds.
The old man begins to realize that Chloe is
a special child and brings her back home.
On their way, he tells Chloe about her mother,
Mary, and gives her a picture of her.
He reveals that he is actually Chloe’s grandfather,
Alan.
Before parting ways, he gives her a powder
and tells her to drug her dad when she hears
the ice cream truck ring.
This will make Henry fall asleep and Chloe
can go to the park.
She takes the powder and goes inside.
A few hours later, Henry wakes up and sees
Chloe in her room drawing.
She accuses him of lying about the bad people
outside the house, and the two get into a fight.
That night, she looks at Mary’s picture
and imagines her.
Suddenly, the closet starts making noise again.
Chloe goes in, and sees the ghost she had
seen a few days ago.
But now, she recognizes her as her mother,
Mary.
She introduces herself, but Mary pushes her
away saying that Chloe isn't real and just
a hallucination, so Chloe runs out of the
closet.
Turns out that Chloe also has a long-distance
telepathic ability, and could make other people
at a distance see and talk to her.
In the morning, the father is sleeping while
watching the news.
Chloe silently listens to the news.
From the news, Chloe finds out that they are
strange people, often called the Freaks.
Freaks have super abilities causing their
eyes to bleed out when they use them.
10 years ago, a freak messed up the city of
Dallas and killed thousands of people.
Since then, the government has set up a defence
force against strange people called the ADF.
The ADF arranges for all Freaks to be held
in an underground facility on Mount Madoc,
and Freaks roaming the city are considered
illegal and could be killed immediately.
An ADF agent named Agent Ray reveals her plan
to train the freaks on Mount Madoc to be used
as weapons in battles.
After hearing the news, Chloe is devastated;
she hopes that one day she will be adopted
by the Reeds family, so that she can become
a normal family member and have a mother figure
who loves her.
Later, Chloe is playing with paper toys, wishing
that she lived with Harper.
Just then, Harper and her friends arrive in
the room.
Harper screams at Chloe, asking her why she
is in her room.
The two seem to be in their respective room
but somehow have met each other because of
Chloe’s power.
Harper’s friends make fun of Chloe for not
having a mother.
Chloe cries and screams.
When she opens her eyes, Harper and her friends
are gone, and Mary appears in the closet.
At first, her mother doesn’t believe it
is her daughter and thinks it is just a hallucination,
but she begins to realize that Chloe has telepathic
powers and that it is really her.
Chloe starts talking to her mother.
It turns out that Chloe's mother, Mary, is
also a freak, and she is still alive and being
held in Mount Madoc….but not long after,
her mother suddenly disappears again.
The next morning, Chloe tells Henry about
her mother, but he doesn’t believe her.
Seeing no other way to escape, she tries to
drug her father.
Henry realizes what she’s doing, and chases
her to the door.
She commands him to sleep and he slips down
to the floor as Chloe’s eye bleeds for the
first time.
She meets Alan in his truck and he tells her
about his plan.
Alan explains that Chloe's mother is still
alive, but is being held captive on Mount Madoc.
He plans to go to Mount Madoc, by meeting
an ADF agent, Ray.
Alan takes Chloe to see agent Ray.
He then makes up a story about him being a
priest and Chloe being his adopted daughter.
He lies that he has just found out that Chloe
is a freak.
He asks Agent Ray to protect Chloe and take
her to Mount Madoc.
And Alan also wants to go there to accompany
Chloe.
Then, Agent Ray checks for traces of blood
under Chloe's eyes to make sure she's a Freak.
Ray also checks Alan's eyes, but finds no
traces under his.
Being called a freak, Chloe gets offended
and yells that she is not a freak.
Ray calls for backup, thinking that Chloe
is dangerous.
Luckily, Alan and Chloe manage to escape by
suddenly disappearing.
It turns out that Alan is also a Freak who
has the ability to become invisible.
He has been using hydrogen peroxide to remove
the traces of blood under his eyes.
The two flee from there; Chloe asks him to
take her back home, but he wants to take Chloe
to his apartment to teach her how to use her
powers so they can help Chloe's mother.
She uses her power to make him drive home.
Suddenly, Henry appears on the road and he
takes Alan and his Truck and they just disappear.
He takes Alan home and ties him to a chair.
Moments later Henry returns to Chloe.
He begins to explain everything to Chloe.
It turns out that all this time Henry is also
a Freak.
He has the ability to create a time bubble
that slows time in the outside world, while
the person inside the bubble performs normally….
All this time he had created a time bubble
around their house which worked as long as
he wasn't asleep.
. To the rest of the world, it had only been
a few months since Chloe's mother was arrested,
but to the two of them, they had been hiding
in the house for seven years.
Deciding it’s time to finally let Chloe
go, Henry takes her to the Reeds to fulfill
their deal.
Steven agrees and introduces them to Nancy
and Harper.
Nancy soon realizes that Chloe is a Freak,
and backs out of the deal, saying that she
didn’t know they were supposed to be taking
in a freak.
Finally, they leave, while begging the Reeds
to not report them to the police.
Back in the house, Henry is shocked to see
Chloe’s eyes bleeding, and realizes that
she already has super abilities.
Afraid to trust her, Henry puts her in the
closet.
There, she meets her mother Mary who is being
held at Mount Madoc, but suddenly the prison
guard drags Mary outside.
When Chloe comes out of the closet, she tells
Henry about her mother.
At first, Henry does not believe her, but
finally, Alan explains everything.
It turns out that when he and Mary attacked
Mount Madoc, they lost, and Alan managed to
escape, but Mary was captured; he thought
Mary was killed, but it turns out that Mary
was only detained.
Suddenly Chloe sees her neighbour Nancy reporting
them to the police.
Chloe uses her telepathic powers to get a
vision of what Nancy is talking about.
Nancy calls Chloe a Freak.
Agitated, Chloe uses her power to influence
the policeman.
He stabs Nancy's eye.
Seeing her eyes bleeding, the ADF agents assume
Nancy is a freak, and shoot her right away.
The Reeds family is eventually arrested by
the ADF, assuming they are all freaks.
Henry is mad at Chloe for killing someone,
but Alan defends her and they fight.
Chloe immediately goes to her room, where
she has a vision of Mary being captured.
Henry and Alan then come, and Henry is shocked
to see his wife.
Apparently, Mary will be put to death soon.
Henry tries to shoot the doctor, but of course
he can’t, because it is just an illusion.
Henry and Alan bid farewell to Mary, but suddenly
Chloe uses her telepathic powers to control
the doctor's mind and uses the device to kill
himself.
Chloe enters the mind of the other officer
to free her mother.
Just then, the doorbell rings.
It is Agent Ray.
She has come to investigate them.
Henry freezes the time and dresses up as a
realtor trying to sell the house.
Alan gives him hydrogen peroxide to remove
the bloodstains from his face.
He lets Ray in, and checks Henry for the bloodstains.
When she doesn’t find any, they talk for
a while.
It turns out that she already knows who he
is.
Meanwhile, Chloe is freeing Mary from the
establishment.
Alan comes to help Henry, but before he can
do anything, Ray shoots him, wounding him
badly.
Alan goes invisible before she can do the
same to him.
She then goes upstairs to see Chloe trying
to free Mary.
She shoots her, but Allan comes in between
and saves Chloe’s life at the cost of his.
Agitated, Chloe controls Ray’s mind, and
makes her shoot herself.
She then says her last goodbye to her grandfather.
Outside, the police have surrounded the house
after hearing gunshots, while Chloe continues
saving her mother.
She controls the guards who are about to capture
Mary, and makes them kill each other.
She then opens the exit door for Mary and
lets her free, Mary comes outside and flys
away using her power.
Chloe falls unconscious, because of the overuse
of her power.
Meanwhile, a missile then locks itself into
the house, and the wounded Henry uses his
powers one last time, to slow it down.
He carries Chloe outside, as the missile hits
the house, burning it behind him.
When Chloe wakes up, Henry says his last goodbye
and tells her that he loves her.
Henry dies from his gunshot wound.
Chloe mourns her father’s death when she
hears gunshots.
ADF agents are still looking for Chloe, trying
to capture her.
Suddenly, the shooting stops as Mary arrive
on time to save her.
Chloe and Mary meet for the first time, and
she promises to hide and protect her forever.
However, Chloe tells her that they don’t
need to hide anymore, and they can live wherever
they want.
Touched by her daughter’s confidence, Mary
flies away with her hands around Chloe.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on notifications, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank you for watching